-Guys, I hope everyone
had a great Thanksgiving.
You know,
today is just about over,
and I already had dinner,
so I thought I'd take a look
at my Thanksgiving bingo card,
if I could.
-Oh, great.
-Yeah, I just want
to take a look at it now.
Let's see how I did.
Alright, let's see.
First up here, we have...
Nope. Didn't happen this year.
-Not this year.
-Not this year. Fortunately.
-Yeah.
-This next square says...
Yeah, I did get that one.
-Got that one.
"Input?"
-Let's see the next square.
I got that one, too.
Let's look at
this next one here.
Yeah.
Whoa!
Next, here's the free space
here. This says...
Everyone gets the free space.
-I got to watch that game, yeah.
-Next square says...
Is this rizz?
-You're like 30, right?
-Is this rizz?
[ Audience cheering ]
-Oh, no, Cher's gonna dab.
♪♪
[ Audience cheering ]
-[ Laughs ]
Up next, there's...
"I think it's
an exclamation point.
There's an exclamation point
instead of the 'L.'"
Alright. Oh, the next one
here -- it says...
Gross. I know what I look like.
-Don't post that.
-And, finally...
Oh, yeah, anyway...
It's another great Thanksgiving.